today we're talking about lost ark
suffering some launch issues on steam
call of duty revealing some season 2
details and more
amazon and smile gay rpg's free-to-play
mmorpg lost ark is live now if you buy
one of the game's various founders packs
which grant a three-day head start
however as pointed out by both players
and the official lost our twitter
account that's not exactly the case at
the time of this recording it seems
there is an issue with being able to
download the game with users getting
connection timeout errors the official
lost our twitter account confirmed the
issue and went on to say it's working
with steam to resolve the issue in one
of the final updates before this
recording lostdark said quote we are now
seeing improvement in players being able
to download and decrypt the game and
have confirmed this with the team at
valve we will continue to monitor the
situation well that's good to hear
hopefully by the time you're watching
this players are having a much better
experience lost ark also put up huge
numbers on twitch as players patiently
waited for the chance to log in and play
amazon is celebrating lost dark's launch
in a number of ways including a twitch
competition where streamers are
competing to conquer the game's
challenges and unlock in-game rewards
for their viewers
switching gears to another online game
call of duty vanguard and warzone the
first cinematic trailer has arrived for
call of duty vanguard and warzone's
upcoming season 2. the new season of
content will arrive on february 14th and
it will feature tanks and threats of
chemical warfare it will also feature
the end of your relationship if you
choose to ignore your boo thing on
valentine's day in order to play this
nonstop with tanks confirmed to be
coming in season 2 vanguard is going to
need larger maps vanguard launched with
16 multiplayer maps but most of the maps
aren't spacious enough for cruising
around in tanks activision's season 2
blog vaguely teases vanguard's largest
map is coming later in the season with
an arms race mode but says more info
will be coming from sledgehammer games
at a later time the cinematic trailers
show scenes of a giant snowy battlefield
with tanks which could point to the alps
as being as the first location of
vanguard's upcoming tank warfare
in other shooter news don't expect to
play fortnite on your steam deck ahead
of the steam deck's launch on february
25th tim sweeney has confirmed epic
games does not have plans to support
fortnite for valve's handheld gaming
device in response to a question by
another twitter user sweeney explained
that epic is working hard to improve
easy anti-cheat capabilities for the
steam deck but just not for fortnite
though fortnite isn't available on steam
the steam deck is designed as an open
platform meaning users can install games
outside of steam's storefront like other
large online multiplayer titles fortnite
faces issues with its anti-cheat
software on steam deck's linux based os
and while some players have suggested
that sweeney isn't keen on having epic's
biggest title playable on rival hardware
it's more likely that the steam deck is
too niche for epic to want to put in the
effort to guarantee compatibility not
long after the steam deck was originally
announced sweeney was one of the first
outspoken fans in a tweet he called the
device a quote amazing move by valve
specifically praising steam's open
platform approach to the device it's
pretty cool that the steam deck is like
out in the wild and reviewers are really
getting to spend some time with it
unfortunately i'm not one of those
people but let me know in the comments
if you're really excited for the steam
deck in which you're hoping to play on
it first
[Music]
[Music]
you